survivors of typhoon haiyan attended
mass on sunday morning at their ruined
church in the town of parlo on lady
island
the parishioners are grateful to be
alive
their community is one of the hardest
hit
this is the only time this is the only
place where we can uh we can unburden
all the things that we are feeling
because of our faith
even if we are the hardships
and pains that we
we are suffering from those who died and
the hardships you are at home because we
have no home already we still have to
go on and thank god for we survive yes
president benigno aquino has again
visited areas ravaged by the typhoon
he and his government are facing
criticism for not getting aid to
survivors quickly enough aquino said
they were doing all they can
i want to stress that the government has
the means at least 28 countries are
healthy in our operations can we rise up
of course but it will be easier and
faster with assistance
rebuilding after the devastation will be
a huge task
tacloban for example was almost
completely flattened
the latest estimates say four million
people lost their homes to the fierce
winds and huge waves